sorry to tell you this guys um but have
some bad news according to the
Physicians committee for responsible
medicine on the website they revealed
that eating eggs can be hazardous to
your health okay and they actually list
several scientific studies that prove
that eating eggs can be very hazardous
and I just want to tell you some of the
conclusions on these studies this is not
good guys eating eggs increases the risk
of dying from heart attacks oh my gosh
I've been eating all these eggs this
whole time and I'm in trouble 2021 study
found that the addition of a half an egg
a day was associated with more deaths
from heart disease cancer in all
causes this is not good this is scary
another study they mentioned eating eggs
also can be connected to developing
certain types of cancer colon rectal and
prostate oh my gosh I'm going to have to
change all my videos change my diet
this is not exciting guys I mean I
thought I was the expert apparently not
well I tell you we're going to uh
explore this topic a little bit deeper
and I think you're going to be Shell
Shocked I'm sorry I just had to do that
before you evaluate a topic okay and you
try to figure out what's Truth Or Not
truth you have to first make sure that
the data is good data not bad data you
want to make sure that you include all
of the data so there's no missing
information you want to make sure you
don't exaggerate the data I have all the
studies right here I printed them out
there's like 10 different studies about
eggs seven of these studies are
observational two are meta analyses of
observational studies one is a review
article and one is a systemic review
these observational studies are based on
food frequency questionnaires none of
them is an experimental study randomized
controlled trial which is a study in
which a treatment procedure or program
is intentionally introduced and a result
or outcome is observed the problem is
with our recall who's going to remember
what they ate in the last 12 months I
don't even remember what I ate last
weekend when I was in practice I would
ask people um you know what did you eat
the the previous week right they
couldn't remember and then come to find
out they kind of exaggerated talking
about all the good things but not the
bad things so it's very very difficult
if not impossible to extract the exact
thing that person ate and the amounts
it's not credible questioner studies do
not prove
causation and as far as an association
yes there's an association but there are
so many variables why do you pick eggs
out of the million variables what about
their smoking what about their drinking
what about their medication side effects
what about their genetics what about
their inactivity what about the Doughnut
that they just ate why didn't you pick
that it's literally impossible to
isolate this link between two things now
at first I couldn't find if they were
actually credible studies that showed
some randomized trials things like that
but then I dug a little deeper and I
found that 100% of those metaanalysis
were complete questioner self-reported
studies so right there I can't even
evaluate whether the study shows any
real substantiation or not because it's
based on questioner studies so pretty
much puts that data into a certain
category not to mention the conflict of
interest uh the Canadian Journal of
Cardiology this showed that those who
ate the most eggs got a higher risk of
cardiovascular disease Dr Spence and the
Dr Davon received fees from several
pharmaceutical companies that sell
anti-cholesterol
medication and Dr Daviston also had
support from fizer Astro zenica and Merc
all right another study uh by jamama um
Dr Wilkins reported receiving
consultation fees from NGM
biopharmaceuticals Dr men reported
receiving research support from various
big Pharma companies and is on their
Advisory Board as well so unfortunately
the Physicians committee for responsible
medicine is putting out doubts uh about
the health of eating anything animal
products they are plant-based physician
group but their membership really is
only 5% Physicians and honestly I think
it's really really bad for someone to
put out information that's just a lie to
scare people into not eating eggs I I
know the news does it all the time
they'll put these little doubts in
people's minds and it's very difficult
for most people the general public to
evaluate that data themselves so they
depend on someone else who's responsible
do it for them and and I think this is
just really a smear campaign on eggs egg
has gotten a bad wrap for many years but
the egg is a very interesting protein
that I want to share right now some
additional information just to give you
some factual information about what's in
an egg first of all an egg yolk okay an
egg yolk um is not a developing chicken
okay it's the nutrition for that chicken
the egg yolk is probably one of the most
nutrient-dense multivitamin mineral
phytonutrient substances that you can
consume based in some additional protein
around that egg yolk the egg is almost
complete with about every single
nutrient except vitamin C but it's
loaded with vitamin B1 B2 B3 B5 B6 B9
and b12 it's one of the best sources of
vitamin A and I'm talking about the
active form of vitamin A called retinol
you cannot get retinol from carrots okay
in carrots you have the precursor beta
carotene that is supposed to convert
into the active form of vitamin A um you
have to get it from animal sources or
egg sources but vitamin A which is so
crucial for your eyes for your immune
system for your skin especially the
inside of your skin the sinuses the
throat the lungs even the colon anything
internal skin is supported by vitamin A
and of course liver has the highest
amount of vitamin A but egg Yol is right
up there as well it has vitamin E that
by the way supports the inside of your
heart eating eggs is going to help your
cardiovascular system it's going to
support the inside layer of the arteries
because it has vitamin E as well as
Vitamin K2 which is really important in
removing the excess calcium in the
arteries it keeps the calcium out of the
soft tissues of the body it is vitamin D
very few foods have vitamin D
but egg yolks have it and of course I'm
talking about um an egg that comes from
a pasture raised healthy chicken okay
I'm not talking about this chicken
that's in this cage their whole life but
the egg is the best source of protein
the most quality source of protein
behind breast milk it's a super
bioavailable source of amino acids it
also is the food that has the second
highest amount of
choline behind liver and choline is
important in reducing fat off your liver
it's important in supporting the brain
because it makes this neurotransmitter
called acetylcholine to help your memory
it also has minerals potassium magnesium
selenium it also has omega-3 fatty acids
as well which is good for the heart um
another uh thing that it can do is it
can increase the particle size of your
LDL what does that mean there's two
types of LDL you have the small dense uh
particle size which is the one that kind
of invades the arteries it creates more
problems creates more inflammation but
then you have uh something else that's
bigger called a large buoyant particle
size and that's the one that is not
pathogenic also eggs can help reduce
your insulin resistance think about the
carb level on eggs there's not a lot of
carbs and eggs so it's a perfect keto
combination of protein and fat and
nutrition also can increase hdil it has
lutein and zanthin what are those those
are carotenoids you see those in
vegetables but the bioavailability in
vegetables doesn't even compare to the
bioavailability from an egg so these two
carotenoids
protect not just the eye because it's
good for the eye against like things
like macular degeneration and cataracts
but also protects the endothelial tissue
inside your arteries so no eggs don't
cause heart problems okay they help
heart problems so consuming eggs is an
excellent idea and the next time you
hear some bad news about eggs um take a
look at the study uh make sure it's not
an observational study make sure that
the source of the study it doesn't have
conflict of interest but the egg can be
a super heart healthy food to consume
now if you haven't seen my new Resource
page on my website drberg.com where I
have a lot of very cool downloads so go
there now and check out all the onepage
summary um things that I have on various
topics I think you'll really enjoy
them